[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy tuesday we're
going to take you back about a year and
a few months to the day america change
you may not have noticed it at the time
but this really was the pivot point it
was the height of the blm riots early
last summer and rioters in minneapolis
had just torched a bunch of different
buildings and standing right in front of
them was an nb msnbc reporter who was
broadcasting live from the scene now the
mob began by torching small businesses
all through the city including a liquor
store which of course they looted first
naturally
then as the rioting accelerated they
walked down the street and burned down
the third precinct police station the
minneapolis police station
now as you saw that happen you realize
this is a little different from anything
we've seen before we've seen riots
before in 1992 following the rodney king
verdict riders in los angeles torched a
lot of the middle of that city
but they didn't burn any police stations
because you can't burn a police station
because they're police there and they're
armed and they represent the law they
enforce the laws you can't burn down a
police station because if they let you
do that then you know the whole system
is crumbled
and yet that's exactly what happened
just days into the blm hysteria last
summer a police station was burning and
the implication of that was very clear
this is why we don't allow police
stations to get burned because the
message it sends is this the police
can't protect you
they can't even protect themselves so
the police aren't in charge legitimate
authority is gone the mob is now in
charge
so as this is happening there happens to
be as noted a reporter standing right
there with a microphone and a camera
taking those pictures directly into your
living room that reporter was called ali
velshi now he's famously not super
bright but he was on the scene
watch how he described what was
happening right behind him
the fire edges can't get in here there's
no ability to bring anybody in here to
solve this problem so i i want to be
clear in how i characterize this this is
a mostly protest
it is not
it is not generally speaking unruly
it's the greatest tape effort you've
probably seen it a hundred times we
watch it every morning just for
edification it's mostly a protest he
said flames in the background it's
generally speaking not unruly
while standing in front of a burning
building
so that tape as we just said is very
famous and a lot of people look at that
and they say that reporter is a [ __ ]
which of course is true he couldn't even
describe what he was seeing accurately
what a gaff
but it wasn't a gaff it was not taken
out of context in fact it was msnbc's
explicit editorial policy to lie about
what you were watching live to
characterize violent riots as peaceful
protests and it wasn't just alive
that very day probably the oiliest of
all msnbc anchors a character called
craig melvin explained the network's
approach to the story and we're quoting
this will guide our reporting in
minnesota well the situation on the
ground in minneapolis is fluid and there
has been violence it is most accurate at
this time to describe what is happening
there as protests
not riots
painting doctor orwell not right now
they're not riots the one thing these
things aren't when they're torching the
police station
looting the liquor they're not riots
oh not at all
but msnbc was not an outlier in adopting
this policy of reality denial here's
what cnn's coverage looked like at the
time
and let's not forget if anyone is
judging this i'm not judging this i'm
just wondering
what is going on our country was started
because this is how the boston tea party
rioting
so don't do not get it twisted and think
that oh this is some something that has
not never happened before and then this
is so terrible and where are we in these
savages and all of that this is how this
country was started yeah this is totally
normal we've been dealing with this for
hundreds of years sam adam himself
torched a wendy's and looted a liquor
store before burning down a police
station in downtown minneapolis is how
this country started we've always had
riots and looting virtually every day
it's totally normal so your job as a
viewer
per cnn msnbc new york times the
atlantic the washington post all the
rest of them was to remain calm
acknowledge that this is just the way
things are this is the way they have
always been
and accept it
the country your ancestors built is on
fire but shut up because your ancestors
also burned it down
now that's not true in fact it's
grotesquely untrue you have to be
historically illiterate to believe it
many people are unfortunately but it
worked because propaganda does that's
why they do it so instead of pushing
back against this rioting most americans
kind of went along with it well it
doesn't look quite right to me but this
is how our country started that's what
don lemon said so i'm gonna kind of go
along with it in other words as your
quality of life declines you are
instructed not to notice
this trend has continued the washington
post just ran this headline and we're
quoting
don't rant about short staff stores and
supply chain woes
rather than quote living constantly on
the verge of throwing a fit
we do ourselves a favor by consciously
lowering expectations got that so if you
don't like the fact that the shelves are
bare in your local store don't throw a
fit don't be an entitled little tool
lower your expectations what did you
expect in america
come on
breadlines we've always had breadlines
it's sort of charmingly retro these
bread lines
don't complain
as your life becomes worse and as your
country degrades
that's the message and not surprisingly
that message is coming directly from the
people who are making your life worse
and destroying the country that of
course would be the white house
here's his grouchy little flack today
almost impossible to believe this person
is real and not just some sort of
mock-up of like a wesleyan gender
studies student apparently she is real
and today she was asked about these
supply chain problems like our ports are
shut down what do we do
watch as she mocks the reporter's
question how dare you ask watch this
just a question on the timing on the
supply chain issue
actions that the president has taken
it was clear in march of 2020 when
coveted hit that that the supply chains
across the world had been disrupted even
as as the sort of work to fight back
against coburn proceeded
people it was it was crystal clear that
things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and
and furniture and treadmills delivered
on time not to mention all sorts of
other things
so why is the tragedy of the short the
treadmill that's delayed the
problem but but here's the serious point
is why didn't the president
act sooner in a more aggressive way
were you complaining about not having a
treadmill settle down karen what do you
want to exercise you've got netflix and
weeds shut up get back to your cube be
happy lower your expectations and if you
do go outside if you notice the
walgreens is for example closed and so
is the cvs because everything in there
has been stolen by thieves who have now
been redefined to civil rights
protesters stop complaining karen it's
always been this way now san francisco
has very few walgreens or cvs's or
stores like that left because they've
all been looted
by civil rights protesters but that's
not a problem according to the mayor of
san francisco in fact as she explains in
this amazing piece of tape it's really
walgreens fault
ultimately
you know they've made their decision we
have tried to work with them in order to
ensure that we are covered in terms of
having pharmacies all across the city
this is going to of course impact a lot
of our neighborhoods but i wouldn't say
go as far as to say they can't do
business they still have
a lot of stores everywhere you look
almost every corner you'll see a
walgreens and some of these stores are
not just closing because of retail theft
they're closing because they're not
necessarily bringing in the sales that
they once did so i don't want to
attribute that completely to just retail
that
uh-huh so you're so tempted to say well
if you elect a mayor that dumb then you
kind of deserve what you get
but the truth is not everybody in san
francisco voted for london breed despite
her alluring name they don't deserve
this no one deserves this the truth is
you shouldn't have daily looting in
american cities because it's a first
world country this isn't some third
world hell hole this is once again the
country that our ancestors built it's a
great country it's a clean country it's
an orderly country people don't steal
you're not allowed to steal
okay period
but all of a sudden you can steal and
our leaders are telling you you've
always been able to steal it's okay
you bring your kids to school and oh
wait a second they're junkies living in
tents right across from your kid's
school
well that they've always been there too
they were there when you're a kid you
just never noticed just readjust your
expectations settle down karen
here's seattle's mayor jenny durkin
explaining that children are going to
have to deal with the junkies living in
tents right next to their school here's
a local news report from seattle
broadview thompson is a k-8 public
school its property includes this green
belt which was taken over by dozens of
homeless that neighbors say are bringing
even more problems this morning in my
garden
i found an empty
packet that had drugs in it despite
outrage from neighbors and parents whose
kids are just now able to return to
their school two seattle school board
members are refusing to let the
encampment be cleared mayor jenny durkin
decided not to intervene claiming the
public school property is private
property and off limits without an
invitation
yeah so the one thing you can't do is
expel the junkies not the homeless
homeless makes it like some sort of
protected class of protesters they're
junkies they're people shooting up
breaking into cars to support their
habit
selling themselves pimping out women
they're junkies okay and they're on your
kid's school lawn
but we can't intervene in that because
it's always been that way just lower
expectations karen
in new york city police have just been
ordered not to intervene when they see
junkies shooting up on the sidewalk or
in a park can't get in the way
and you shouldn't because we've always
had junkies in our park sam adams was
actually smoking meth on the boston
common once upon a time in washington dc
the metro just basically shut down and
pulled 60 of its train cars from service
so commuters the ones who pay for it are
just have to find another way to get to
work because the train service isn't
working anymore
just lower your expectations in fact
they're lucky in philadelphia last week
several people on a train they got on
the train and then they got to watch as
a man raped a woman on the train for
minutes
witnesses describe what they saw at fox
29 in philadelphia here's part of it
at upper darby's 69th street station
passengers of the market frankfurt line
are outraged the attack was brutal it
was wicked and the worst party when the
people were watching several people
watching some within arm's length says
upper darby superintendent of police
arrested his 35-year-old fishton noy who
investigators say is seen on a trained
security camera sitting next to the
alleged victim touching her and then
raping her investigators say a female
septa employee called in the attack
which was relayed on radio about the
attacker disrobing on a train at 56th
street station septa says noye was
arrested at 69th street station on the
train in the
act this has always been
the way america works remember kitty
genovese she was killed and nobody said
anything the difference though
we were shocked by that
55 years ago when she died in this case
passengers watched this woman get raped
but they were on their phone
they were online gaming
the police chief of philadelphia of
pennsylvania's transportation authority
said that nobody who saw it
did anything about it
i can tell you that people were holding
their phone up
in the direction of
um this woman being attacked
and by attack just to be totally clear
and i hate to use the word but it's the
right word she was raped in front of all
these people and they did nothing
so how'd this happen
i was talking about root causes what
were the root causes of this rape
we can tell you tonight that the 35 year
old congolese man who apparently raped
this woman his name is fisted nagoy has
a criminal record and shouldn't have
been here in the first place he was on
an overstayed student visa he should
have been deported this should never
have happened he should not have been
here and the only reason he was is
because he and a lot of people like him
have been invited here and allowed to
stay by the people who run the country
but who don't ride the train
this particular man first came to the
united states in 2012 he's on a student
visa now that visa ended in 2015 because
he was no longer a student
court records show that nagoya racked up
quote multiple arrests and two
misdemeanor convictions one for
controlled substances and one for sexual
abuse
okay so here's someone in the country
illegally
who is convicted of sexual abuse and
drugs but he's still here
so why aren't the people who allowed him
to remain here in jail themselves they
certainly should be
now this guy was put into immigration
detention back in january of 2018 but he
never got deported because the
immigration legal system decided that he
should receive a special stay of removal
oh so he got what's called a withholding
of removal from an immigration judge two
years ago back in 2019. according to
court documents that decision came after
quote the board of immigration appeals
found the petitioner's misdemeanor sex
offense was not a quote serious crime
just a minor sex offense and therefore
he was ineligible for withholding from
from removal
so to recap you can walk into our
country at the invitation of our leaders
at public expense you can overstay your
visa and so doing mock our laws then you
can get busted for drugs and a sex crime
not deported allowed to stay and then
you'll go on probably inevitably at this
point to rape a woman on a train
in full view of a crowd that does
nothing to stop it
but it's always been this way don't get
up tight readjust your expectations
you want more of this we may be getting
it today joe biden's nominee to lead the
border patrol a guy called chris magnus
set for his confirmation hearings
now it turns out that magnus if anything
is to the left of biden even to the left
of barack obama on immigration matters
just a year ago when he was the police
chief of tucson arizona magnus rejected
a federal grant that was part of a
program called operation stone garden
that was supported by the obama
administration now the point of the
program was to help border towns fight
cartel violence and drug trafficking
that would seem a worthy goal not really
directly related to immigration directly
related to the deaths of hundreds of
thousands of americans but chris magnus
in his wisdom rejected that money
his own police department was outraged
by this but chris magnus didn't care
because he's a deeply good person unlike
you he's happy to have bet the deaths of
thousands of americans by drug ods he
said that this money and this mission
stopping drug cartels didn't align with
the work he's doing
that work of course is opening our
country's borders
so here you have the person who's about
to oversee our country's border security
who does not believe in borders
now if that bothers you in any way if
you think we should be deporting rapists
instead of letting them rape women on
trains then the white house has a very
clear message for you shut up karen stop
complaining those arsonists are an
arsonist they're mostly peaceful
protesters that treadmill
you don't deserve a treadmill lower your
expectations
get used to it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else